more than two years until the
presidential election national Democrats
are going local Ohio state senator Nina
Turner is campaign to unseat the
incumbent Secretary of State a
Republican has become a piece of a push
by the National Party to boost voter
enthusiasm and lay the groundwork for
2016 a Secretary of State can make or
break the environment of voting they
could use those tools at their disposal
so we need somebody that's going to be a
fair operator the issues Republican back
changes to voting laws the strategy is
dual tracked organized early in States
to boost supporter enthusiasm and
elevate battleground secretary of state
races which has trended Republican in
recent years and it certainly is going
to be a turnout election Democrats
believe the message of expanding access
to the polls is a winner
while Secretary of State races get
little attention on the national level
they track tightly with the party's push
how big of an impact can a secretary
state have when it comes to elections
Secretary of State can make all the
difference these are the folks who
control the levers for elections
Pratt y Lee sends staff and resources
into battleground states to reverse the
drop in turnout expected in midterm
elections for election lawyers like wily
secretaries of state are crucial they
establish election day procedures and
force voting rules and oversee election
conduct for the DNC party big guns like
President Bill Clinton and Vice
President Joe Biden have been brought
out to juice interest and fundraising
for the effort it's time to stand up and
to fight back
at the same time two outside groups
focused solely on Secretary of State
races have pledged grassroots campaigns
hundreds of thousands of dollars and the
expertise of powerhouse Democratic
consulting firms it's time to fight back
and it really flipped the switch to go
from defense which we've been fighting
for a long time on voting rights
actually go on the offense meet Jeremy
Bird
so you just put up so many resources
right he's one of the strategists behind
Ivo a group running campaigns backing
Democratic Secretary of State candidates
in four states including turns in Ohio
still Democrats face the very real
question of whether they can actually
raise money to play in these state races
especially when Democrats face losing
the majority in the Senate and party
enthusiasm is down Byrd says one person
who's not even on the ballot is one of
their best weapons they're looking
towards 16 for Hillary Clinton
specifically is that helpful when you
talk to people about this yeah
absolutely there's no question that the
Secretary of State's who are elected in
2014 will have a massive impact on the
presidential race in 2016
people who really care about Hillary
Clinton who believe in her potential
candidacy in 2016 care about these races
that's where Ohio comes in Turner has to
make up a 7 to 1 cash disadvantage to
incumbent Republican Jon Husted the
outside help matters George says her
races about state issues still she's
keenly aware of what a win could mean I
get why people are paying attention to
this Ohio is the swing state of swing
states